okay that was something high glamour its
Montana and I'm here to tell you how to
nail your love island audition okay so
the first thing that I would recommend
is to just dress up dress up glam ladies
and gents okay get your winged eyeliner
on points because you will be on camera
and they will be showing the execs so
it's best to look your best on that
special so my next tip would be just try
and stand out don't blend into the
background remember some really funny
stories when you went out with your
girlfriends tell them that story don't
just say oh I'm really fun yeah but why
are you fun like what makes you fun what
makes you different so try and remember
that I would also say just be really
enthusiastic and so the first ever
interview that I had it was a group
interview and there are some people that
look like they don't want to be there
and you are being interviewed
you need to excited so I would recommend
being completely yourself obviously I
never thought I'd get on the show but I
was completely honest from day one I
don't really drink that much I'm not a
massive party animal I don't smoke I was
in Chamber Choir like so say all those
points because that's probably why I got
on it because I was just really weird
and a bit different to everyone else and
I think it kind of sets you apart from
what you're partying or get drunk alone
or which one I think it sets you apart
and you might think it's weird but they
think it's interesting if you if you are
you know you are part Chamber Choir
I was Maria and there's none of music so
obviously they liked it
so now the tip that I have is to really
mentally prepare yourself that it could
change your life just from that one
audition I know I definitely wasn't
prepared at all I didn't have an agent I
was kind of going through all this and
happy goal ra didn't think anything was
going to happen from it so my life
really turned upside down I went from
students on a budget we all know the
feels and then suddenly I've got 1.2
million it's very very odd so my last
and final very important tip is to kind
of be fearless that is your one chance
to kind of nail it
there's your probably amongst a hundred
thousand applicants so you really do
need to give it your all and just own it
you know if you're part Chamber Choir
own it if you pop a rock band own it if
you're a bomb-disposal person like
camilla own it and so that is definitely
my my wives pearls of wisdom and then
you might end up with your own range of
petty little thing you know dreams can
come true